probably SBF and FTX is the biggest
thing you've ever covered but previously
you've called the save the kids scam the
world's influence the scam like the the
the the biggest in the world influences
cam you've ever seen uh can you describe
it
sure so save the kids was a charity coin
that was launched by
a number of extremely popular
influencers I think they had over 50
million followers together
huge names and they basically said hey
guys invest in this coin We're Gonna
Save the kids
a portion of the proceeds go to charity
and this coin it's unruggable so rugging
is the term for remember earlier we
talked about safe Moon you just grab the
pool of funds in the middle and you take
them out okay it's unruggable because we
have this smart code that is going to
prevent
people who are quote whales which is a
crypto term for saying you have a large
portion of the tokens
it'll prevent those people from selling
a large amount of that at one time right
and so basically you don't have to worry
about trusting us it just is what it is
join and we will you know change the
world save the kids whatever the CH it
was really skeezy from the beginning and
sketchy because their logo matched the
save the children logo which is like an
actual charity that you know so they
basically copied it and said we're
saving the kids
um like a knockoff brand and almost
immediately the the project rugged the
they stole the money and tracing back
through
the code was just changed at the last
second before launch like if you looked
at their code that they launched as a
test versus the code they launched in
actuality they changed only like two
lines and it was the whale code to
basically make the whale code
non-existent like you can sell as much
as you want as fast as you want
um and it turned out that some of the
influencers had not only
sold that and made money but also had a
pattern of pump and dumping tokens so we
can talk about what that is like yeah
what's pumping up a pump and dump is
just where you know you have a huge
following you promote your little Lex
coin to everybody while holding a big
portion of it and as everyone rushes in
to buy it the price is going to pump
and you dump at the same time so that's
where the name comes from pump and dump
you pump the price sell all your tokens
make a lot of money so I traced
basically their Wallets on the
blockchain and found that two of the
actors specifically had had a long
history of doing this
um
which really proved malicious intent and
why I called it the worst is not it
certainly wasn't the worst in terms of
like the amount of people affected it uh
relatively was like a small pump and
dump because it rugged almost
immediately
but in terms of the amount of people
that were involved in it in terms of the
amount of malicious behavior before it
that like sort of proved that this
wasn't an accident the fact that there
was like this whale code it was one of
the most cynical attempts to just take
the money of the followers you had and
just like
that's mine now so that's that's why I
called it that let's save the kids so
that was uh that was a lot of the phase
members and uh it was I think Addison
Ray there are a lot of people who seemed
like they were kind of taking shrapnel
on it there was like this guy Tico who
he didn't even sell the tokens he just
like held on to it the entire time and
lost like a few thousand dollars or
maybe even I forget the exact amount he
lost a lot of money a decent amount and
so like he took a lot of shrapnel with
that but there were also people who were
maliciously doing this so
in that investigation like several of
the members of phase got kicked out one
of them got like permanently banned and
then this other guy that I talked about
fled the country like he sold all his
belongings and like fled the country and
you know hid out in in London or
wherever he is now I don't really know
where he is somewhere in the UK area so
the basic idea there is to try to
convert your influence into money
correct
okay that's the basic idea behind a lot
of influencer crypto promotions
well but right but that that little word
influencer means something because
they're our most crypto scams influences
scam they're not right most most cut
right most high profile ones like just
by Nature they tend to be made high
profile by the influencer so sometimes
they are but you're right a lot of money
has been lost and like nobody finds out
because there's no one big sort of
attached to it they just steal a lot of
money but
um influencers are great sales people
because like in order to overcome the
resistance of getting you to buy some
random coin there has to be a reason and
so much of the 21st century content
creator generation is defined by these
strange parasocial relationships where
people feel like they know you not the
character you play but you and you have
some friendship with them when in
actuality you don't know the viewers you
know you have a sense but you don't
actually know all of these people and so
so that relationship is extremely
powerful in terms of persuasion so you
can say I believe in this and I've
watched you year for years and all of a
sudden I say if Lex believes in I
believe in it I trust him as a human and
so that differentiates these coins and
all of a sudden the coin blows up gets
really popular yeah you made this side
deal you make a ton of money I have to
say podcasting in particular is an
intimacy like I'm a huge fan of podcasts
and I feel like I'm friends with the
people I listen to right and boys that
are responsibility yes
and that's that's why it it uh really
hurts me to announce that I am launching
Lex coin now
no man I uh this uh the the I hate money
I hate this kind of the scheminess of
all of this the the use the use of any
kind of degree of Fame that you have for
that kind of stuff there's something
just so like frustrating is these
people's disgusting I have a general
sense of what they were like sort of
what I'm I'm in the even though I
wouldn't describe myself as an
influencer I make content on YouTube
I know that especially since they were
taking these huge corporate sponsorships
they were making tons of money they
didn't have need for these scams I mean
I think it's one thing to scam if you're
like broke on the street you know and
you're playing three card Monty to like
live and I think it's a whole other
ethically cruel thing to do if you're
basically trying to upgrade your
Penthouse to the building next door and
like you're already well off and you
just kind of want to get even further
ahead I think that's where